Una vez, cuando éramos pequeños, todos aprendimos
que Asia es el continente más grande y más
poblado del mundo, y que dentro de Asia también
estaba el país más habitado del planeta: China.
Sin embargo, esto ya no es así.
N1(24 de abril de 2023: India supera a China
y se convierte en el país más poblado )
Efectivamente, lo que durante tanto
tiempo se pronosticó al fin ha ocurrido:
la India ha superado a China en población.
Según las estimaciones, en julio de 2023,
la India ya supera por unos escasos
3 millones de personas a China,
sin embargo, esta diferencia se va a ir
incrementando con el paso del tiempo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, los expertos
estiman que la población de China caerá de
forma constante hasta los 800 millones para
finales de siglo. Mientras tanto, la India
tocará los 1.700 millones en el año 2060 y cerrará
el siglo con unos 1.500 millones de habitantes.
Es decir, que para finales
del siglo XXI la población
de la India prácticamente duplicara a la China.
¿Y qué supone esto? Pues para China
todo un reto. Por ejemplo, para el 2050,
habrá 700 millones de trabajadores en China,
es decir, 200 millones menos que en 2011,
y estos 700 millones, además, tendrán que
hacer frente a los costes que supondrá tener
500 millones de chinos mayores de 60 años, 300
millones más que en la actualidad. Y, no solo eso,
China también se arriesga a perder una de sus
mayores fortalezas: la mano de obra barata.
Sin embargo, hoy no os vamos a hablar de China:
hoy venimos a hablaros del nuevo campeón
demográfico en que se ha convertido la India.
Un país que sigue siendo muy pobre y que todavía
no ha conseguido igualar a China en cuanto
a productividad económica o nivel de vida.
Y, la pregunta es ¿por qué no? Pues
podríamos destacar muchos elementos:
Una excesiva burocracia, un agresivo
proteccionismo, el sistema de castas
del que recientemente os hemos hablado,
y también su incapacidad crónica para
desarrollar un factor crucial para el desarrollo
económico: tener una fuerte infraestructura.
Que es precisamente a lo que
vamos a dedicar este vídeo.
Pero, queridos amigos, ¿cómo ha llegado
la India hasta aquí? ¿Cómo está afrontando
Narendra Modi el reto de la falta crónica
de infraestructuras? ¿Puede convertirse la
India en el nuevo epicentro mundial de
las manufacturas? ¿Qué industria puede
poner en jaque los planes geopolíticos
de Xi Jinping? Hoy vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas, pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(LA DINASTÍA POLÍTICA INDIA)
Empecemos con una pregunta que
os puede pillar desprevenidos:
¿qué sabéis de la historia de la India?
Seguramente muchos sabréis contarme algún
dato sobre el Mahatma Gandhi y su apuesta
por la no violencia. Y, seguro que
la mayoría también sabéis que fue
una antigua colonia británica. Pero…
¿Algo más? Lo más probable es que no.
Normalmente de la India solo nos resaltan su
enorme población, sin embargo, este gigante
es mucho más que eso y su historia es
crucial para entender la actual India.
(Independizada en 1947 del Imperio
Británico bajo el liderazgo de Gandhi,
la India es un Estado federal relativamente
joven. Desde su comienzo tuvo que afrontar
un escenario económico muy poco productivo
basado en la agricultura de subsistencia;
hasta el 70% de la población vivía de ella. Sin
embargo, tras el asesinato de Gandhi en 1948,
llegó al poder su compañero y figura
principal de la independencia:
Jawarharlal Nehru, y entonces la India comenzó
su camino hacia el desarrollo económico.
El nuevo primer ministro de la India comenzó a
dirigir la economía desde el propio Estado y en
1951 creó el primer plan quinquenal del país. Este
plan nacionalizó la minería, el sector energético
y la industria pesada. Todos ellos fueron
clasificados como sectores estratégicos. También
se implantó un estricto sistema de licencias que
engrosó desmesuradamente la burocracia. Lo cual
hizo que durante su mandato, el cual se extendió
hasta 1964, la economía apenas lograra crecer un
2,5%. Un nivel insuficiente para acabar con el
desempleo crónico, la pobreza o la desnutrición.)
Más tarde, con la muerte de Nehru en 1964
y de su sucesor, Lal Bahadur Shastri,
en 1966, llegó otra de las figuras más
importantes de la historia del país:
Indira Gandhi. No, no es la hija
del Mahatma, sino del propio Nehru.
Indira Gandhi gobernó desde 1966 hasta 1984 de
manera casi ininterrumpida a excepción de los
3 años que transcurren entre 1977 y 1980. Durante
el resto del tiempo fue dueña y señora del país.
Y, ¿qué es lo que hizo durante sus
dos mandatos? Pues, básicamente,
continuar con los planes económicos de su padre:
nacionalizó el sistema bancario, las minas de
carbón y las compañías petroleras, entre otras.
Sin embargo, pese a todo, seguramente
el principal hito de la primera ministra
india fue la erradicación, casi por completo, del
hambre a través de la conocida Revolución Verde.
¿Y en qué consistió esta revolución? Pues
esencialmente en la introducción de cultivos con
rendimientos mucho más altos, como el arroz enano;
el uso generalizado de fertilizantes y pesticidas
y la mejora de los sistemas de regadío.
No obstante, en octubre 1984, 4 meses
después de producirse un enfrentamiento
entre el estado y los separatistas de la
religión Sikh, fue asesinada por algunos de sus
guardaespaldas que profesaban esa misma religión.
Pero, amigos, si creíais que eso de las
dinastías políticas era solo cosa de los Kennedy,
craso error. ¿Sabéis quién tomó las riendas del
país tras el asesinato de Indira Gandhi? Exacto,
su hijo, Rajiv Gandhi. Y, ¿qué
hizo exactamente? Realmente no
cambió demasiadas cosas, continuó con
el legado de su madre y su abuelo.
Pese a todo, al final, durante los años 80 la
India logró crecer por encima del 3%. E, incluso,
tuvo algunos años razonablemente buenos.
La evolución dado el nivel de pobreza del
país no era para tirar cohetes, pero
aparentemente tampoco un desastre.
Sin embargo, el problema es que este
crecimiento tenía gato encerrado. Durante años,
la India creció a base de deuda. Y, como ya
pasó en América Latina a principios de los 80,
la India sufrió una crisis financiera en 1990.
Fue entonces cuando, en 1991, siendo primer
ministro Narasimha Rao, la India comenzó a
abrirse al mundo: se redujo drásticamente
la burocracia eliminando buena parte del
sistema de licencias de Nehru, disminuyeron
los aranceles y las reservas monetarias
acabaron creciendo desde los $3.000 millones
en 1991 hasta los $25.000 millones en 1995.
Sin embargo, a la India le seguía faltando algo
que consolidara y expandiera su crecimiento
económico, algo que su vecina China ya estaba
desarrollando: infraestructura. Pues bien, así
comenzó el impulso de la infraestructura en este
subcontinente de Asia. Prestad mucha atención:
T2(“MAKE IN INDIA”)
Un país necesita infraestructura: sin carreteras,
sin centrales eléctricas o sin tecnología,
difícilmente un país puede prosperar en el siglo
XXI. Por eso mismo en África los países trabajan
tanto con China, porque el gigante asiático les
facilita préstamos y ayuda para construir todas
esas infraestructuras básicas que resultan
indispensables para alcanzar el desarrollo.
Pues bien, de todo esto se dio cuenta en la India
el primer ministro Atal Bihari Vajpayee en 1998,
y por eso impulsó el famoso proyecto
llamado “Cuadrilátero de Oro”.
Un proyecto que conecta por carretera
4 de las principales ciudades del país:
Nueva Delhi en el norte, Calcuta en
el este, Chennai en el sur y Bombay
en el oeste, todo con miras a mejorar los
intercambios económicos dentro del país.
Pero, desde luego, este impulso no se quedó ahí.
Su sucesor, Manmohan Singh,
que llegó al poder en 2004,
impulsó la construcción de los corredores
dedicados al transporte de mercancías por tren.
De hecho, hizo de estos el eje principal
del plan quinquenal de 2007-2012,
y hoy ya están en funcionamiento 2 de estos
corredores: el occidental, de 1.500 km de largo,
y el oriental, que es el más largo. Con
1.900 km de longitud va desde Ludhiana,
la ciudad más poblada de Punjab, hasta Dankuni,
que es parte del área metropolitana de Calcuta.
No obstante, pese a todo, lo cierto es que
los avances seguían siendo demasiado lentos.
Y claro, en un país tan poblado y con
ciudades extraordinariamente grandes
os podéis imaginar el enorme problema
que eso supone: carreteras colapsadas,
trenes atestados de gente circulando
a velocidades extremadamente lentas,
cortes de electricidad, problemas con los plazos
de entrega de las mercancías, etcétera, etcétera.
Pues bien, fue entonces, de pronto, en 2014
cuando irrumpió en la política nacional
india una particular figura de la que ya os
hemos hablado en este canal: Narendra Modi.
Ya os hemos contado en otros vídeos cómo está
manejando Modi el país: las denuncias por la
violación de derechos humanos son constantes
y muchas de sus promesas económicas quedaron
en prácticamente nada. Sin embargo, sigue
siendo un político muy popular en el país.
Y, precisamente, uno de sus grandes
empeños ha sido y está siendo mejorar
las infraestructuras. Y no como sus predecesores,
sino a lo grande. Y todo bajo una
iniciativa: la iniciativa “Make in India”.
(Impulsada en 2014 por el propio Modi, la
iniciativa “Make in India” busca hacer de
la India el hub manufacturero más importante
del mundo, incluso por encima de China. El
objetivo es que el peso del sector de las
manufacturas pase del 17% actual a más
25%. Por el camino esperan crear de paso 100
millones de puestos de trabajo en este sector.
Para ello, el gobierno de la India se ha centrado
en construir una mejor infraestructura que sea
capaz de atraer más inversiones e incentivar la
innovación de 25 sectores concretos, entre los que
destacan la energía, los productos químicos, los
sistemas electrónicos o el sector automovilístico.
Por el momento, la iniciativa parece
estar dando sus frutos, ya que desde
el año fiscal 2012-13 hasta el 2020-21,
el año principal de la pandemia del Covid,
la Inversión Extranjera Directa pasó de unos
34 mil millones de dólares a tocar los 82 mil.)
Durante este tiempo, Modi ha impulsado la
construcción de más 10.000 km nuevos de
autovías cada año, se han construido más de 45
nuevos aeropuertos civiles y hay decenas más en
construcción. Se han desarrollado nuevos puertos,
nuevos sistemas de transporte metropolitano y
también miles y miles de kilómetros de nuevos
ferrocarriles a lo largo y ancho de todo el país.
Con todo ello se persigue, además, un objetivo
crucial: lograr reducir los costes logísticos del
país, que se sitúan en un 14% del PIB, a menos del
8% del PIB para el año 2030. Una infraestructura
eficiente resulta absolutamente clave para
la competitividad del sector industrial.
Ya lo veis, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, Modi
le ha puesto las pilas a la India para intentar
superar a China no solo en población, sino
también en manufacturas. Ese es su gran objetivo.
Así que para el primer ministro indio
esto no ha hecho más que empezar.
De hecho, el presupuesto de 2023 dedicado a la
construcción de infraestructuras ha crecido un
33% con respecto al año anterior hasta alcanzar
el 3.3% del PIB, es decir, $122.000 millones.
Además, también han decidido extender
los préstamos sin intereses a 50 años
para todos aquellos gobiernos estatales
que quieran invertir en infraestructura.
Y, no solo eso, la inversión en inteligencia
artificial, sobre todo para su incorporación
en la educación, también es uno de sus ejes
fundamentales. Y, cómo no, se va a seguir
invirtiendo en los corredores de mercancías,
tanto en los dos que están ya casi acabados y
que están funcionando ahora casi al 100%, como
en otros 3 proyectos que ya se han aprobado.
Sin embargo, y a pesar de la
construcción de infraestructura,
hay un problema que podría alejar
la inversión hacia la India:
N2(Oscuras noches de verano: India se enfrenta
a un alto riesgo de cortes de electricidad
tras años de abandono del carbón
y la energía hidráulica. Reuters)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos,
hablamos del suministro eléctrico.
La India ya lleva al menos 3 años con cortes
de electricidad, sobre todo nocturnos,
debido a la escasez de carbón y su
pobre y anticuada infraestructura. Y,
como ya os podéis imaginar, esto supone un
problema fundamental para toda la industria.
Para solucionar este problema, la India
tiene proyectada la construcción de 26
plantas eléctricas de carbón en los
próximos 10 años. Sí, sí, carbón.
Sea como sea, lo más seguro es que la India
aún tarde décadas en alcanzar a China como
principal productor de manufacturas del
mundo, si es que lo consigue algún día.
Por supuesto, esto no significa que la India
no vaya a convertirse en un actor económico tan
crucial como lo es hoy en dia China. Incluso, hay
una industria que, de llegar a desarrollarse en
la India, podría llegar a desbaratar muchos
los planes geopolíticos de Pekín. Atentos:
T3(LA GEOPOLÍTICA DEL SEMICONDUCTOR)
Hackers una pregunta: ¿qué componente
electrónico necesitan un móvil, un coche
o incluso un misil teledirigido para poder
funcionar? Seguramente muchos no lo sabréis,
pero es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado tanto
en nuestro canal hermano, VisualEconomik como
en Si lo Hubiera Sabido. Si aún no los cono
céis os dejo los enlaces en la descripción.
Os estamos habla ndo, por supuesto, de
los semiconductores. Y, ¿sabéis qué país
tiene todo el potencial de convertirse
en un punto principal de la producción de
semiconductores? Efectivamente, la India.
Veréis, Modi no pretende crear e impulsar
empresas desde 0 en la India, sino atraer a
grandes firmas al país. Y tampoco es una locura.
Pensadlo bien, tienen cuatro ventajas: un gran
mercado interno, un amplio conocimiento del
inglés, una mano de obra relativamente muy barata
y una de las mayores canteras de licenciados en
ciencias, tecnología, ingeniería y matemáticas.
Por todo esto, no es de extrañar que ya nos
estemos encontrando con noticias como estas:
(ISMC Digital invertirá $3.000 millones en una
unidad de fabricación de chips
en Karnataka. EconomicTimes)
(Foxconn y Vedanta construirán en la India
una fábrica de chips por valor de 19.000
millones de dólares. BBC)
Y precisamente esto,
queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, es
uno de los mayores temores de China.
Pero la pregunta es, ¿por qué? Pues veréis, como
ya sabéis, India y China no son precisamente
los mejores amigos del mundo: mantienen
reivindicaciones territoriales y ambos
países ` aspiran a convertirse en la
principal potencia regional en Asia.
Por ejemplo, China ha estado ewxpandiendo su
poder por el Mar de la China Meridional y, aún
más preocupante para la India, por otros países de
Asia como Pakistán o Sri Lanka. Pero por su parte,
India también ha hecho lo mismo, jugando con su
posición geoestratégica en las islas del Mar de
Andamán y fortaleciendo vínculos con países
como Omán, las Islas Seychelles o Indonesia,
puntos clave que llegado el caso podrían
cortar el suministro del crudo que llega
por mar desde el Golfo Pérsico hasta China.
Hablamos de una incipiente lucha que ha
llevado inevitablemente a que la India
se acerque cada vez más a Estados Unidos:
N5(Biden hace concesiones y Modi sale de
su zona de confort durante una elaborada
visita de Estado a la Casa Blanca. CNN)
Pero ¡ojo! Este acercamiento no solo
le interesa al propio Modi, sino
también a la administración Biden:
C1(“Estados Unidos necesita a India como socio
estratégico para equilibrarse frente a China
tanto en el sur de Asia como en el Indo-Pacífico,
e India necesita a Estados Unidos a medida que
desarrolla un futuro más próspero y ecológico” –
Caroline Grey, analista de Eurasia Group, 2023.)
Hablamos de una alianza que en Washington
consideran absolutamente clave para contener
a China. No solo por el enorme peso económico
y político que la India adquirirá durante los
próximos años y décadas o porque este país puede
ser una alternativa natural a la dependencia que
el mundo occidental ha desarrollado hacía las
fábricas chinas, sino también por una razón muy
simple: la vulnerabilidad geopolítica de Taiwán.
Y, os preguntaréis, ¿qué tiene que ver Taiwán
aquí? Pues mucho: recordad que Taiwán es el
mayor productor de semiconductores del mundo.
Si la producción taiwanesa se parara
repentinamente por una posible invasión china,
el mundo entraría en pánico y, quizás también,
se detendría una parte importante de la economía.
Los semiconductores son cruciales
para la industria de todo el mundo.
Precisamente por eso, Estados Unidos está
invirtiendo de manera decidida en esta
industria. Por ejemplo, en agosto del año pasado,
se aprobaron leyes que incluían una inversión de
más de 50 mil millones de dólares para fortalecer
su propia producción de semiconductores. También
están presionando para que empresas taiwanesas
como TSMC trasladen allí parte de sus operaciones.
N6(TSMC invertirá $40.000 millones
de dólares en Arizona con su segunda
planta de chips semiconductores. CNBC)
Hoy Estados Unidos produce en torno
al 12% de todos los semiconductores
del mundo, muy por debajo de Taiwán,
una isla que además produce la inmensa mayor
parte de los semiconductores más avanzados.
(Pues bien, si tal y como se pretende, se consigue
hacer crecer la producción de chips en países como
Estados Unidos, Japón o la propia India, además
de Corea del Sur, China perdería una importante
baza estratégica. Su capacidad potencial
para amenazar a las economías occidentales
con la invasión de Taiwán se reduciría mucho.)
Y no solo eso. Si la India logra posicionarse en
este campo, probablemente eso también animaría
a muchas empresas tecnológicas a trasladar
aquí su actual producción en China.
Y como veis en toda esta historia,
las infraestructuras resultan absolutamente
claves. La India necesita conectarse al mundo
y lograr que su economía pueda funcionar de forma
ágil y barata. Necesita que los profesionales y
las mercancías puedan moverse de forma rápida
y económica y necesita también garantizar un
suministro eléctrico abundante y competitivo.
Pero, queridos amigos, llegados hasta aquí,
las preguntas son ahora para todos vosotros:
¿Creéis que la India conseguirá superar también
económicamente a China? ¿Logrará convertirse
en uno de los principales productores de
semiconductores y reducir el riesgo que supone
China? Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis que
aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.